[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: I think developers
have a common language, even
though we come from different
cultures and backgrounds.
MALE SPEAKER: We're able
to speak in terms of code.
MALE SPEAKER: Everywhere in the
world, if there are hackers,
they can become
like best friends.
MALE SPEAKER: You can throw five
of us from all over together,
and we can just go out
and build something.
MALE SPEAKER: We're all
striving towards the same goal,
and that's to make a
difference in people's lives.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And change the
world using technology here.
MALE SPEAKER: There's loads
of developers out there
that want to just
share their experience.
So--
MALE SPEAKER: Find
the developers!
And meet them, and form or
join a community with them.
MALE SPEAKER: Learning from
others and teaching others
is more important to
us than anything else.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Google
I/O in San Francisco--
it's the time you get to
learn a lot of new things.
You get to meet people
from all around the world.
MALE SPEAKER: Google
I/O happens once a year,
and it shouldn't be all
about just San Francisco.
Google I/O Extended isn't
just a satellite event,
it's an event in itself.
And this is an opportunity to
meet all of the developers that
are making your
community happen.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
I/O Extended-- it
gives a sense of a
global community.
MALE SPEAKER: We want to
build the next generation
of technologies
that will improve
our countries and our societies.
MALE SPEAKERS: Join us.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [FOREIGN].
MALE SPEAKER: [FOREIGN].
MALE SPEAKER: Join me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]